bonjour thierry amouroux merci de
répondre à nos questions sur arte france
ne pas oublier les gestes barrières et
faire un test aux voyageurs en
provenance de pays à risque comment
est-ce que vous accueillez les annonces
ce matin d'olivier ferrand oui c'est
effectivement très très important pour
l'ensemble de la population de bien
conserver les gestes d'arrière de porter
le masque dès que vous êtes dans un
endroit confiné vraiment de faire
attention parce que on est quand même
très très inquiet par rapport au risque
de deuxième vague
on ne sait pas quand est-ce qu'elle
pourrait avoir lieu quelle serait la
hauteur de la vague
on a vu que de nombreux pays c'est
arrivé à 50 60 jours après le
déconfinement c'est à dire maintenant
pour pour pour la france donc on
voudrait pas être obligé de repasser par
des nouveaux confinement partiels le
président du conseil scientifique jean
françois delfraissy redoutent une
deuxième vague justement à l'automne est
ce que vous partagez son inquiétude
alors oui on redoute une nouvelle vague
je ne sais pas quand est-ce qu'elle
pourrait avoir lieu et qu'elle serait la
hauteur mais oui il faut vraiment avoir
les gestes barrière ne le problème c'est
que nous avons des politiques qui disent
ça mais on a un comportement inverse
dans les réunions le public
c'est à ces intervenants passation de
pouvoir cette semaine lors du
remaniement c'est ça tout à fait ou
également au niveau des élections
municipales
que ce soit au moment de l'élection par
elle-même ou de l'élection des maires
huit jours après la photo du ségur de la
santé où on voit le premier ministre les
ministres de la santé et 30 personnes
dans un petit local
collés les uns aux autres sans masque
ça donne une très mauvaise image de
l'exemple à suivre donc
il faut pas non plus dire aux français
ce que vous faites c'est pas bien 6e eux
mêmes n'ont pas des comportements
responsables devoir d'exemplarité donc
c'est ce à quoi vous appelez dans le
même temps aujourd'hui enfin ce soir
minuit c'est la fin de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire avec un aspect politique un
aspect administratif un aspect également
sanitaires quelles conséquences
justement
est ce que vous vous redoutez ou pas
vous savez c'est une mesure purement
administrative maintenant le le message
qui peut être envoyé aux français c'est
peut-être au bas c'est bon on peut
baisser la garde non surtout pas il faut
continuer à se protéger les uns les
autres en portant les masques en
respectant les mesures barrières parce
que le virus il y est toujours là on
mesure les la présence du virus dans les
eaux usées on voit que ça ça la présence
du virus augmente donc il ya il faut
rester quand même très vigilants
est-ce que les hôpitaux français sont
prêts en cas de deuxième vague
malheureusement les leçons du covin
n'ont pas vraiment été tirés c'est à
dire que nous avons des masques
chirurgicaux en quantité maintenant nous
manquons de masques ffp2 ces masques
spéciaux pour les professionnels de
santé en situation de de soins et on
commence à rationner les gants à
avoir des soucis en terme de 2 / blues
alors que depuis deux mois on est en
phase descendante
donc s'il y avait une deuxième vague on
va être certainement confronté à une
nouvelle gestion de manque et c'est un
vrai souci
l'église dont on voit bien que la leçon
n'a pas été tirée par par le
gouvernement et on est quand même
inquiets au niveau des des médicaments
anesthésiques c'est pareil on est en
tension donc on est inquiet quel regard
est ce que vous portez sur ce qui se
passe en mayenne avec une explosion de
contamination dans ce département des
tests massif qui vont être effectués ces
prochains jours si on ne peut par
confiner la france totalement que les
économique oblige confiné localement est
ce que ce sera efficace
oui bien sûr vous avez mais lourde par
exemple qui ont entièrement confinée
donc des millions d'habitants ce sont
des mesures qui sont parfois nécessaires
pour éviter que l'épidémie s'étende
mais surtout ce que chacun peut faire
c'est respecter les mesures barrières
conserver les masques dans tout de me
fermer
voilà chacun à son niveau à agir
seulement 1 respecter les gestes
barrière en rappel c'est ce qu'a rappelé
ce matin olivier verront de ses voeux il
indique également que des tests
salivaires vont être effectués dans les
prochains jours dans les aéroports pour
d'esprit dépister les personnes en
provenance ans l'adie de pays à risque
est-ce que c'est suffisant pour vous
est-ce que les aéroports sont là
le premier mur pour pour la france avant
un éventuel deuxième bail c'est
important de tester un maximum de
populations à l'eau ms nous l'a
recommandé depuis le mois de février
la france a beaucoup de retard en la
matière parce que là où s'il avait un
problème de de manque de test et ça
permet justement de suivre l'évolution
des choses est de limiter la diffusion
en identifiant les les porteurs pour les
isoler le plus rapidement possible le
fait que ce soit des tests salivaires
c'est plus facile moins traumatisant que
le perdant dans la narine donc plus de
gens peuvent peuvent le faire et c'est
quelque chose de très important tester
tester tester
merci thuram ou d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
porte parole du syndicat national des
professionnels infirmiers